public dans sa lettre adressée aux
français et publié hier il l'écrit la
phrase suivante en matière d'immigration
une fois nos obligations d'asile remplie
souhaitez vous que nous puissions nous
fixer des objectifs annuels défini par
le parlement peut-être vous
souvenez-vous que c'était dans la
programme présidentiel de françois
fillon qui était que comme je crois que
ça se passe au canada chaque année le
parlement puisse dire voilà le voici le
le nombre d'immigrés et voici le profil
dont nous avons besoin pour notre pays
bonne idée mauvaise idée sébastien
pots-de-vin d'abord je suis étonné de
retrouver cette question de
l'immigration associé à un moment où
l'on parle de justice sociale et fiscale
parce que ça voudrait dire de manière à
peine voilée qu'il y a un effet de cause
fin d'une relation de cause à effet moi
je fais un peu embêté là dessus parce
que donc si demain on limite comme il se
doit
l'immigration tout ira mieux d'abord je
n'y crois pas ensuite c'est pas parce
que il y a je dirais d'un point de vue
international une dynamique qui fait que
ce sujet là effectivement prendre
l'ampleur qu'il faut tout de suite si
associés dans l'espoir peut-être de
récupérer une partie de l'électorat de
françois fillon pourquoi pas je pense
que le plus grand chose à récupérer de
ce qu'on nous de ce point de vue là ça
me pose un vrai problème
ça ne veut pas dire qu'à un moment ou un
autre il ne faut pas parler
d'immigration
je suis pas en train d'évacuer le sujet
parler d'immigration dans un moment de
tensions extrêmement forte
ça me semble être une mauvaise solution
donc la réponse à votre question pour
moi aller simple la réponse est c'est
une fausse bonne idée
c'est même une mauvaise idée alors dire
qu'ils pensent comme vous mais pas du
tout pour les mêmes raisons et qu'on va
entendre tout de suite c'est jordan
bardella alors peut-être que vous le
connaissez pas encore c'est le la tête
de liste à nouveau neuf récemment
désigné par marine le pen pour mener la
liste du rassemblement national aux
prochaines élections européennes
et voici ses arguments il était ce matin
chez nos confrères de rmc
pas de quotas les français veulent qu'on
mette fin à la politique migratoire cvo
confondues
qui en sortira sondages à quelques
semaines qui nous disent que 80% des
français considère qu'on a accueilli
beaucoup trop d'immigrés dans notre pays
qu'il faut mettre fin c'est voler et moi
ce que je veux dire aux français aussi
c'est que quand on veut on peut
voilà en italie monsieur calvin et l'a
fait baissé de 65 % les demandes d'asile
en quelques mois dans son pays d'origine
par une politique dissuasive
d'immigration alors je mets encore un
élément nouveau au débat pour dire que
nos internautes eux ne sont ne sont
plutôt favorables à l'organisation de ce
débat en tout cas su que ceux qui réagit
sur twitter puisque 72 % nous disent oui
le parlement doit fixer les objectifs
annuels de quotas d'immigration
laure mandeville votre votre point de
vue sur ce projet d'abord ce qui est
frappant c'est que on a le sentiment
qu'il y à une telle panique au sommet de
l'état que tout d'un coup complètement
comment dire délégitimer par ce
mouvement qui finalement en gros est un
mouvement anti macron est qui qui cesse
de répéter qu'il faut qu'ils s'en
aillent
le président essaie de raccrocher d'une
certaine manière
l'intérêt de l'opinion et donc on a le
sentiment qu'il met ce dossier de
l'immigration dont pour ma part j'estime
qu'il est absolument fondamental est que
c'est probablement une inde et des gros
sujets dans les français veulent
précisément parler sur lequel ils
veulent une vraie conversation donc mais
mais la manière dont ces dons c'est fait
pas par macron alors qu'il avait
complètement rejeté cette idée des
pot'arts me paraît effectivement pas
très convaincante du coup dans la
démarche
l'autre élément que je voudrais que tu
lis ça me paraît assez opportuniste et
l'autre élément c'est que il me semble
que le problème des quotas il touche en
réalité l'immigration économique
si je comprends bien et donc c'est un
est-ce que c'est véritablement
aujourd'hui ce qui fait problème dans la
question de l'immigration je n'en suis
pas sûre c'est que je regardais par
curiosité avant l'émission le comment se
dispatchent justement les chiffres de
l'immigration par an je regardais par
exemple sur l'année 2010 est autant que
ses statistiques soient soit soit
valable celle de gawker auquel j'ai eu
accès vous aviez
je crois un chiffre d'environ deux cent
soixante deux mille paires personne qui
est à rentrer avec des titres de séjour
en france et là dessus vous aviez je
crois environ 30000 ou 39 min 40 est
entré au titre de la demande d'asile ou
d'airé pour des raisons humanitaires
vous aviez 90000 qui rentrent en 98
mille euros au titre du regroupement
familial et après vous aviez je crois
quelque chose comme 40 minou ou qui
étaient là pour l'immigration économique
donc on voit bien qu'on parle de la
question de l'immigration tel que les
français là là là là comment dire la
fantasy ou en tout cas on parle elle est
assez floue et de quoi est-ce qu'il veut
exactement par les six et des migrations
de choristes ou est ce que c'est des
étudiants aussi où il y en a je crois
que 88 milles qui rentrent actuellement
à tout ça et me paraît pour l'instant je
sais pas j'ai l'impression d'une
improvisation sur cette question pour
compléter ce que vous disiez
effectivement a priori ce qu'on comprend
c'est que les quotas je serai juste pour
les les
les gens dont la france a besoin pour
travailler alors même que l'essentiel de
l'immigration jaune est une immigration
familiale soit par regroupement familial
soit par mariage essentiellement et que
là c'est un droit et que donc le
parlement n'aurait pas son mot à dire là
dessus
julia de finale ce oui moi j'ai un peu
de mal lundi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec
tout et la logistique humanitaire me
semble toujours très opportuniste là
dans le cadre de cette lettre là
maintenant aujourd'hui parce que on a
l'impression qu'on voit dans les
migrants à l'heure avec le jeune là je
ne vois pas à part de publier son nom
dont qui voit dans les migrants une
occasion de rallier quand même quelques
électeurs à la cause minuscule de leurs
propres idées c'est un peu ça qui est
sous jacent et ça me fait penser un peu
aux syndromes de sganarelle vous savez
ce valet tongiens qui moralise tous et
qui a des très beaux discours une fois
que don gens meurent ils oublient toute
la morale et il pense à son intérêt
privé c'est à dire à son argent ce qui
donne aujourd'hui que seraient des
milliers noyer à côté de la possibilité
qui m'a offert de gagner quelques voix
c'est exactement ce que je ressens dans
cette lettre c'est vraiment une tactique
je trouve
opportuniste populiste d'appuyer sur ce
sujet qui fait qui est sensible pour les
sujets et se dire bah là on oublie toute
morale parce que je j'ai en tête la
phrase d'euros car je sais très bien
qu'on peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde etc
mais en même temps c'est à dire qu'on
qu'est ce que c'est que s'est noyé à
côté de quelques voix que je peux gagner
j'ai l'impression vraiment de cette
inversion morale dans ce quand ça arrive
dans ce cadre dans cette lettre là à ce
moment là précisément quelques réactions
d'internautes de gea cher qui nous dit
l'instauration de quotas me paraît
logique c'est une manière de réguler les
flux
monsieur babineau nous dit la france ne
peut pas avoir de quotas comme le canada
carla flux d'immigration est beaucoup
trop important et cette immigration et
non contrôlés en europe ronito nous dit
l'immigration économique et légale est
liée aux besoins économiques du pays et
les besoins économiques du pays doivent
être définies par les acteurs
économiques pas par les parlementaires
olivier la motion sur ceux sur cette
opportunité de mettre ou non
l'immigration dans le débat on se
souvient que le président avait parlé
c'était l'un des cinq thèmes et puis
finalement il n'y avait plus que quatre
et puis finalement même si c'est pas un
thème en soi l'immigration revient alors
même qu'on n'en parle pas beaucoup sur
les ronds-points alors à votre avis que
c'est légitime de remettre ce sujet dans
le dans le grand débat moi j'ai toujours
eu du mal à comprendre de quoi on
parlait dans les ronds points parce
qu'il ya tellement de choses et des
choses tellement contradictoires j'ai
l'impression qu'on parlait surtout de
tout effectivement moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on fait un procès un peu difficile un
peu d'empathie mettons nous un peu à la
place
akrout utilise sa place vous commencez à
dire faire un thème et puis on va
limiter à la bronca on a tous dit oh là
là mais les questions qu'on ne pose pas
ses les questions dont on n'a pas envie
d'entendre les réponses donc il faut que
tout soit ouverte et on lisait tout à
leur façon à ce qu on veut tout mettre
sur la table mettons tout sur la table
on peut pas faire un débat où on
commence par dire il ya des choses dont
on n'a pas le droit de parler parce que
c'est celle dont visiblement on aura
tous le plus envie de parler donc eh ben
il a fini par se dire pas très bien vous
voulez parler d'immigration
parlons-en parce que on peut pas nier
qu'une demande de ce point de vue là et
il faut quand même pas faire de
manichéisme sa oppose pas les égoïstes
sans coeur et puis solidaire et
humaniste
il ya un moment donné où il faut
entendre depuis ça fait 40 ans que ça
monte
l'inquiétude des gens sur leur identité
est-ce que c'est pas un moment donné de
la justice de la raison est aussi bon
pour tout le monde d'imaginer que dans
le cas effectivement d'une immigration
économique on se dise
est ce qu'on ne doit pas vérifier les
capacités des personnes à s'intégrer
économiquement peut-être assez intégrés
socialement
alors effectivement ce sont le
regroupement familial soyez là lui soyez
pas lieu s'il a lieu de toute façon on
ne peut pas choisir ya pas de quotas il
veut pas comment on pourrait faire des
quotas
évidemment aussi pour des réfugiés
politiques ne pas y avoir de quotas mais
pour les réfugiés économiques
un moment donné où justement on dit que
on peut manquer de certaines compétences
que ce sont des compétences qui vont
être utile mais il y en a d'autres qui
sont pas utiles ça peut paraître quelque
chose d'assez sens c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de pays en réalité le font déjà
on serait bien sûr de le faire ce qui ne
résout pas en réalité le problème de
fond puisque on a bien vu que
quantitativement c'était en fait une
partie assez marginal en fait d abord si
on avait pu parler tout on aurait pu
parler de l' isf et on ne l'a pas fait
alesis qualité il faut parler faux pas
oui mais c'est bien pour ça que moi j'ai
quand même une première digue par
rapport à tout ça je peux adhérer ce que
vous dites
alors il fallait tout mettre de nom la
réalité c'est que derrière cette
question de l'immigration est allé
question du modèle occidental du progrès
et
personne autour de septembre n'oublie
aujourd'hui la question du progrès et
posé que la question du progrès comme
étant une une référence historique une
dynamique historique est posée et que
ces questions d'immigration font partie
de tout ce qui de tout ce qui est
derrière mais derrière qu'est ce qu'il
ya les français y voilà trop climat
tendu mais tout ce qu'on avait pu mettre
sur vérins autour de la croissance
autour des bienfaits notamment de la
globalisation autour des bienfaits du
numérique aujourd'hui on envoie un
certain nombre d'effets négatifs
et effectivement il ya des questions qui
sont posées et le renouveau
conservateurs comme on voit apparaître
partout
justement se pose sur ces questions là
donc effectivement la réalité c est ce
qu un moment ou un autre on va poser la
question du modèle français
ne nous cachons pas derrière les
questions d'immigration posons nous la
question de ce qu'est le progrès de ce
peut-être les limites du progrès parce
que la limite il faut pas être enfermée
dans une vision et là on pourra
commencer à en profondeur évoluer les
choses
il ya un autre point sur ces sujets
d'objectifs annuels c'est que ça
sous-entend probablement une immigration
économique peut être aussi une
immigration réversible c'est que si les
besoins de l'économie peuvent changer ça
veut dire aussi qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent venir et à qui on peut dire à un
moment comme le font d'autres pays
d'ailleurs nous n'avons plus besoin de
vos compétences et ça c'est pas facile à
faire accepter
culturellement et puis surtout ça pose
la question du regroupement familial
c'est à dire que si vous ça veut dire
que vous ferez changer de modèle cet
accord est donc c'est qu'elle devait
venir les compétences mais pas les
familles des gens qu'on voit là dans ces
cas là vous faites venir les
vous faites venir effectivement les
compétences vous avez besoin avec des
contrats particuliers ça existe
d'ailleurs mais c'est effectivement
c'est pas du tout ça serait une
révolution culturelle qu'est d'ailleurs
peut-être en marche honnêtement ça
forcément en marche mais en marchant
marc fues mais à mon sens l'un des
problèmes qui nous guette alors ça
paraîtra bizarre et peut-être botté en
touche mais en fait c'est plutôt les
migrations
c'est à dire l'espèce de sécession des
élites de départ des élites qui de plus
en plus qui a commencé depuis très
longtemps la différence c'est qu'elle
fait pas beaucoup de bruit
ça fait un moment en réalité qu'elle a
commencé que tous les gens pourraient
dire qu'ils le peuvent ont tendance à
avoir de plus en plus leur avenir en
dehors de france
le vrai drame probablement c'est
celui-là c'est cette propension des
élites à vouloir partir quand on n'est
pas attractif pour les gens on pourrait
dire qu'ils entreprennent qui crée le
plus de valeur et ça fait un lien
finalement avec psf là un pays peut se
poser les problèmes parce que les
conséquences après elles sont
économiques elles sont sur les recettes
fiscales
ils sont sûrs de capacité à avoir des
parts de marché donc à maintenir notre
modèle social
grâce à la valeur concret cette fois
c'est qu'on est paradoxal sur les
compétences en france parce que on
justifie les migrants avec des
compétences donc on mise beaucoup sur
les compétences il se serait un prétexte
pour essayer truies nausicaa ce qui est
illogique et qui ne peut pas relever du
logique les migrations et en même temps
sur les compétences des élites ça on
n'en veut plus de tout ça sans qu'ils
aient des connaissances et des
compétences ses élites aux phobies et
les combes et les compétents qui partent
de france ça pose - problème mais pour
ceux qui arrivent il en faut des forces
ces fouilles à ce qu'on paie de ses
compétences ont un mot fourre tout dans
lesquels on peut tout justifier
le possible comme l'impossible je vous
propose de laisser le dernier mot sur ce
sujet à un internaute à l'aigle qui nous
dit je ne sais pas si les quotas auront
un impact sur l'économie
mais ce qui est certain c'est que ça
calmera les craintes de beaucoup de
français donc oui il le faut je suis sûr
qu'on va revenir sur ce sujet et sur ce
point de débat dans les semaines à venir
je propose de changer de thème encore
que on n'est pas vraiment loin
marine le pen la présidente du front
national a lancé hier sa campagne pour
les européennes
mais avant de l'écouter je voudrais
qu'on regarde ce résultat l'un des
résultats qu'on a publié dans le figaro
vendredi dernier de l'étude annuelle du
cevipof le cevipof
c'est un institut très sérieux de
d'étude de la vie politique française
qui dépend de sciences po et qui fait
tous les ans un très grand sondage sur
le rapport des français à la politique
et là on dit on a posé la question en
qui avez vous confiance et regardez ce
ce rêve